[Music]
families everything so that comes first
Kris Jenner dishing on her famous family
like never before in Fox News's latest
series objectified Kris opens up about
her strange marriage with late husband
Robert Kardashian who is the father of
her eldest children Kourtney Kim khloé
and Rob I married Robert when I was 22
years old and had I got pregnant on my
honeymoon I had the happiest life you
could have dreamt about but when you're
in something you want sometimes people
think the grass is always greener and
that was like what I think I went
through at some point ultimately Kris
admits she cheated on Rob with a soccer
player I did I did which wasn't nothing
I'm proud of when I look back on it now
probably one of my biggest regrets in my
life is that that marriage fell apart
still the reality TV family has stayed
United over the years despite Kris
affair and Kim Kardashian scandalous
past like major major drama
when asked if Chris thought daughter
Kim's infamous sex tape with Ray J made
their family famous she said quote I
can't control what other people say and
obviously that was a hard thing to go
through it was devastating
adding the thing I learned from that is
that you can get through anything as a
family we are so blessed to have the
best support system and the best family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
[Music]